welcome back to the jenna julienne
podcast it feels good to just be
recording and really here we really out
here you want to tell them what happened
it's been a rough day guys rough day so
we are currently using onion we're
currently using our new interface we had
a new preamp that i set up for the
podcast and we've never recorded with it
it should make our mic sound the most
professional they could ever sound but
meanwhile you've been noodling like all
week positing a thunderbolt port
I've been noodling around oh yeah in
this software like it's been a process
to get it up and running it's been a
process and we're not even fully up and
running because I'm currently running it
off my macbook not a PC that we're
supposed to be running off of anyway as
you know by the title probably we are
having an interview on this episode of
the jinjo podcast with a girl named
Madison who was at tanah comm we came up
here earlier and I thought I could be
crafty and fancy and conduct the whole
interview here we were discord with you
guys watching us yeah and that wasn't
the case because we did the whole thing
and then I clicked and recording and it
says operation could not be complete was
like it's literal nightmare like that's
the stuff of nightmares it was yeah I
was pretty nauseous about it but anyway
so we did the interview again Madison
was such a trooper yeah so that's where
I'm at um now I look at a screen or an
SD card and I just cringe a little
anxiety a little bit yeah so we we
wanted to talk about annicon real quick
oh go ahead um I just had some really
yummy pizza and it was only made
possible by post mates delivering it to
our house and speaking of post mates
guys I'm sponsoring the podcast fact so
you did I did I just had as usual your
stomach like the rest of your life
are at war okay and you need you need to
get the food you need right now and you
can't go to the store okay you can't
pick a takeout what's that
I don't know we'd really like Post mated
a lemon from the grocery store looking
you post me to anything absolutely find
out anything okay like you can get a bar
of soap for your dog I think
Pizza the worst thing I've ever post
waited was a fire pit from Target
you literally post me in a fire pit yes
I did guys post mate is the app that you
download on your phone 24 hours a day
365 days a year they deliver all the
favorite restaurants and stores and
things like that to to your front door
very quickly their app lets you track
where your delivery person is and it's
just one I mean the it's amazing right
now guys
use code Jenna Julian okay and you get a
hundred dollars of free delivery credit
for your first seven days when you sign
up using post mates check it out more on
that later also guys quip the toothbrush
from the future it's a really small
amazingly designed toothbrush that is
super affordable ok it starts at just
$25 and if you go to get quip commnets
GE tqu IP comm / Jenna Julian you get
your first refill pack for free because
they send you refill pack packs of the
bristles so they don't get broken down
and then not do their job that's what
quips all about is an efficient good
brush right now click the link below to
get your first refill pack on us thank
you so much sponsor thank you so much
sponsors um I know you guys want us to
get into this podcast we're here now um
so Tana Khan was this past weekend I
guess you consider weekend news Friday
right yeah same time as VidCon I don't
think we should do too much of like
explaining what it is I think you get if
you're watching this you know what it
probably know what it is and if you're
completely under a rock give them the
deal I'll get I'll give you the TLDR
it's so VidCon is the largest YouTube
convention on the planet has been for
many years
I'm very interested we did not go or up
for the first time in a long time we
just wanted to take some time off
honestly like there's not some boiling
hot tea with us and VidCon um it's just
a very big convention which is pretty
corporate and you know it's it's a lot
it's it's a very it drains you yeah to
go yeah that's intense for sure about
20,000 people I guess we're expected to
go this year it was the first year that
it was owned by Viacom which I'm excited
to hear feedback from maybe
some of our friends that are willing to
let us know maybe I'll get back to you
guys about that because I want to see
how that went
tanah mojo is a creator she just turned
20 years old today happy birthday Tana
but she last year was in escape the
night which is like one of the bigger
YouTube red shows by Joey Graceffa and
you know was meant to be a featured
creator I didn't watch her whole video
explaining it so I don't know all of the
details nor did I but she essentially
was treated like she wasn't meant to be
there and got like escorted off and they
were like well there's people that want
to meet me and you know you can't at
VidCon like we saw with Logan Paul
running out to the fountain and be like
just meet me on the fountain like it it
causes stampedes
it causes security hurt like it's very
dangerous for a reason so they escorted
her away and just acted like she wasn't
supposed to be there which she very
clearly was supposed to be there and so
she made a video about it talking about
it and then sort of as a [ __ ] you to
VidCon
she decided half as a joke at first I
think to create an icon which would be
she wanted it to be free for people to
go and meet their favorite creators and
VidCon and playlist or other conventions
you pay money you buy a ticket and you
go and it was a misconception for years
that we were getting paid to be there
you're not I mean they'll give you a
flight in a hotel pretty much if you're
traveling to Orlando or if people had to
travel to Anaheim they'll give you
accommodations but then you know you're
there to do what you have scheduled and
you do have say what's in your schedule
like they're not forcing people to do
stuff yeah yeah but you know you're
you're there to participate in the that
large event and and community and meet
people that want to meet you and you
know if you wanted to promote stuff I
guess that's in it for you or if you
wanted to talk on a panel mm-hmm but
there's not really like you're they're
not giving us anything to go you know I
mean like this you just get incentive
this to me you got exactly so
I was upset about that it's so expensive
and you know people had bought tickets
at VidCon to see her and they never did
which sucks
I mean we've we've done a lot of events
all over the world like there are times
when it's just out of your [ __ ]
control and it's really heartbreaking to
get tweets from people that are like you
know her waited all day and I drove all
the way from wherever and I flew here
and it's it's really heartbreaking
because at the end of the day she
created this event to sort of try and
make that better for people and she just
wanted to create something that was like
fun for her fans and in that sense I
don't knock her at all to commend her
you know she's a was a 19 year old girl
at the time trying to create an event
where she could do that safely with fans
but it did not turn into that it turned
out horribly way too many people for
capacity showed up there was there were
people waiting on the Sun for five plus
hours getting sunburned there were no
water and food stands for people the
security was little to barely present
and we learned a lot of this from
speaking with Madison Co here and just
being on Twitter of course yeah she said
something when we first talked to her
you guys won't hear that cuz I was an
interview I was lost but she said like
leading up to Jannah Khan she was like
slowly gaining respect for Tana because
she was like this is a cool thing like
VidCon did this to her so she's taking a
you know a humorous approach but at the
same time she's meeting her fans so she
was like yeah she was gaining you know
my respect but then as it happened and
it kind of just didn't go right that
kind of all went away and she kind of
went back to square one which wasn't
like she doesn't like ten it was just
like all that respect that she was
gamers like hot damn you know isn't it
like it didn't it didn't happen you know
it was all talk which I think a lot of
people are feeling like so what are we
gonna do now we're gonna play that
interview yeah so I think I think now
you guys can listen to Madison kind of
explain from her perspective what it was
like being at tanah con she was there
for a long time she was in line for a
long
time also if you'd like we're gonna link
her in her highlighted Instagram story
I'll just link her Instagram and then
her highlighted story
I thought she uploaded it to YouTube you
can just check the youtube link I'll
probably put this regardless I'll put a
link her story because her story is like
you know when you have the little pieces
on the other stories hers are like so
small because she did so many because
she basically documented every moment
there every kind of piece of the of the
day oh yeah this is our interview with
Madison who went to Tannen Titanic on
alright take a listen all right well
thank you for being here again Madison I
appreciate it how do you friend Ashley
we can't forget they can't forget about
Ashley so we did go through a bunch of
this prior but as we said the recording
was it vanished into thin air it was
just taken from us so I want to kind of
start like a little bit from being again
about how you started with the decision
to go to technicon and from the point of
Inception to kind of getting there and
seeing like what was going on okay well
I've loved youtube for a while but I
haven't been able to go to any
conventions until I moved to LA but I
still was skeptical of VidCon with like
some of the stuff that's been happening
and I followed a lot of tannaz drama
with it because I had a friend who
volunteered there at VidCon last year
and was like in the room when Tanis sort
of got escorted out of someone's Q&A and
when I saw that she was sort of setting
up this alternative convention and I saw
I started seeing some of the names and
Shane Dawson brought a lot of people I
was also interested in like to think in
the Chamberlain and some of the like you
know smaller youtubers as well and
honestly I was like excited to meet
Danna mojo to like she's sort of a icon
but yeah so I I bought my own ticket and
I did the VIP
[Music]
I think I bought my ticket about a month
ago and then we got an email about kind
of how things were gonna go that they
were gonna be multiple lines for your
last name and when check-in was which
sort of you know they said that you
could start checking in at 6:00 a.m. and
then people later told me they didn't
start checking people in until actually
like 9:00 a.m. so they just sort of let
the the line stack up but when I got
there it was like 9:30 and the line was
already I mean I waited in line for five
and a half hours so it was already five
and a half that was the amount of time
that you ended up in line yeah and in
that time you you did order a pizza
where she talked about it's pretty
legendary two hours and I was like okay
cuz I remember getting to a point and
saying okay I think we're about halfway
and someone no I think we're about a
quarter of the way and I said I'm
post-meeting if he's there right now
okay I was I was not gonna stand there
for another and you said it was a hot it
was a hot day people were getting
sunburned left and right yes I mean you
had said the email also said there was
gonna be registration lines plural with
according to your last name so you
didn't anticipate waiting in one long
ryan line is that really what it was it
was just basically one big long line yes
and there so it was this huge line that
if you see any of the videos from like
the aerial view where there's sort of
like a cluster of people that's where
there's multiple lines I say that in
quotations because it didn't matter once
you got up there you just sort of like
went into a few different lines around
these tables and then they just sort of
like handed out the credentials but they
weren't really checking tickets that
well they were also like if anyone has a
meet-and-greet let me know and they were
just like handing out like the meet and
greet like wristbands and it was very
unorganized yeah and you would said that
someone arrived for their meet-and-greet
was in Colby or Coby
oh I can't remember no his name was she
was it Bradley Bradley yes and that he
showed up and then there were people in
line that were like I have his meet and
greet yeah I go inside yeah so this so
as the meet-and-greet started that day
because you know they have it's a
convention so they had a bunch of events
happening at once people were like I'm
gonna meet this meet or I'm gonna miss
this meet-and-greet and so they started
telling people if you're in the line and
you have this meet-and-greet you can
come up here and honestly like some of
our group was like should we just
because the other issue is that a lot of
people didn't get a chance to like
reserve their meet and greets so with
the with the VIP package that people
paid for you were supposed to get a fast
pass into one meet-and-greet of your
choosing that you had to reserve online
but it immediately got sold out because
people were given that like chance to
reserve multiple I guess and yeah so a
ton of people were like just going to
say that someone was there
meet-and-greet to like try to get in
faster yeah we've known this about
VidCon or other conventions for years
it's like they'll do anything and there
needs to be a system to check because
they'll say anything those loose
witching of wristbands like all kinds of
stuff to get in like it's you know you
can't blame them I'd do the same thing
in you know yeah so you're saying
there's no protocol for like if people
were lying yeah
yeah it was it was sort of an arc yet
especially when I got inside it was
fully just like everyone it was chickens
with their heads kind of offered the
best way I can put it and you uh you
said that you everyone had a certain
color what was the name what was the
color of the the pet passes that most
people had yeah so the name of the VIP
pass was the featured [ __ ] creator
pass and that was the orange pass and
then just to be a featured creator that
sort of horrible joke
um those were like the quote free
tickets those were yellow passes and so
we kind of all started to notice that no
one had the free passes and if they did
they either like we I saw on a vlog that
some girls just got them from a girl
that was like handing them out when I
got up to get my credentials there were
just stacks of the yellow like labels
just like on the table and they were
like scrounging for the orange ones
well it's like everyone that you talked
to pretty much you guys had all paid
like in size the event yeah we don't
know how many people if any actually
went to the event for free which was the
whole point of it yeah I started getting
very like conspiracy theory in the in
the line and of course I kind of said
this earlier but the girls I was with
were so sweet and young and so I was
trying to not like Nathan like yeah I
mean it's like wow they're in their
sunshine but I was like I was like what
if there were never free passes and they
were like no no no no that's not and so
I was like okay I'm not gonna talk about
that anymore but yeah that was and I
heard it from other people too I mean a
lot of people were sort of skeptical of
if that was ever a thing I know they
gave away a few tickets um so those
people technically got the three badges
but yeah I don't know anyone that got
like that like quote bought a free
ticket do Tanna ever say or did good
times ever could firm like how many
tickets they sold there's a lot of
numbers going around I want to say that
Tana once said uh in a tweet maybe and I
think it was before the event like wow
we already sold 5,000 tickets or
something like that which the venue I
never confirmed how many they could hold
but it wasn't 5,000 right now it's just
that one sort of convention hall and now
it's like you know the size for like a
wedding right and then a hallway and
then rooms for me in Greece yes that's
what um so I didn't see any of the meet
and greet rooms like inside of them but
yeah it was it was too small yeah I I
would say the the biggest problem with
that um and like the communication so
along it's sort of all ties together but
they you know in the email they sent out
they said we'll still be selling tickets
on site tomorrow so maybe come maybe
you'll get in and so of course a ton of
people come right what we think but as I
said everyone I know they're paid for a
ticket so I don't know I don't know what
the truth is really but either way a lot
of people are gonna show up if they're
told they might have a chance right well
you're saying aunt Anna had tweeted out
herself that she wanted the event free
that she wanted people's favorite
creators just to be walking around quote
eggs and to just show up so obviously
once you're like there's Casey nice dad
there's Shane Dawson like Gabby show
like people are just gonna be here just
show up right people are gonna show up
exactly if if anything to watch them
walk in and out a lot of people were you
know kind of after all the mess went
down they like staked out by the door
where
the creators came in and out of and just
waited because they knew someone would
leave from there and so like your your
cotton you gave us good context with
your Instagram story your highlight
Instagram story of tannic on and
watching that kind of gives you an idea
of like start to finish like what your
general experience was and I mentioned
this before but like there was a moment
in there when you started to you know
feel like something was going wrong and
it hit you and it felt like you were in
the hallway and if you could like
elaborate on describing that scene
because I think that's when you were
starting to get kicked out and amongst
many other people to make room for other
people who are waiting outside for sure
I mean that oh yeah I want you to
describe that for us again but the there
were people that I saw treating saying
that they were getting pushed by
security and gym stuff like that yeah I
didn't see any physical contact with
security um but I you know I so I can't
speak to that but um yeah so my so when
I got in I'd sort of like kind of as I
said earlier I'd like finessed my way in
to the door but they had already
announced that it was closing down so I
did not know what to expect but when I
went inside they told us they were like
basically hurting us into the main room
like we weren't allowed to go anywhere
else and I I think Elijah Daniel was on
the stage and so we sort of just like
watched these few little filler acts
that came out and including the gabbie
show and when she came out she goes well
this turned into a complete [ __ ] show
but what did you expect it's SantaCon we
were like yep and I think
um it started to really click when like
half the lights came on in the main room
and like this sweet girl who's
introducing the musical act keeps like
coming out and just like she's like it
reminds me of the Mariah Carey dancers
from the New Year's Eve like not I'm not
getting fired today like I'm going out
and I'm like doing my job I'm doing my
job no matter what else she like came
out and she was like hey guys are you
guys ready for some more great music and
we were all like what's going on she
just was like here's Gabby and then like
it was just a mess but then they started
telling us we all needed to leave an
important an important piece of
information is that they went ahead and
reopens
tannaz merch shop while we were all
being kicked out so because they knew
that there would be traffic traffic
because it yes exits I guess I'm not
really sure it like they just came out
of nowhere and all of a sudden people
were buying jackets and I was like sorry
people still vying merch
so so the the merch was closed and then
went when people started getting
escorted out they opened it up yeah it
was like completely dark in the main
room when I went in like like a middle
school dance and then they like turned
on like half the lights and then the
merch table was at the back of that main
room and just out of nowhere the merch
people appeared as we were being told to
leave which was just so in the security
even was like are you guys selling stuff
and they're like as long as they're
buying we're selling it's like wow oh
boy um but I yeah I didn't I didn't have
any physical interactions with security
they did come into the bathroom so I had
waited to pee like this entire time so
like at this point like six hours so I
went in pretty outside and told the
story the first time we talked about
that had like a medical need right
needed to the bathroom right walk into
the hotel and skag her to another hook
bath right so it was it was already kind
of crazy in there um but they came into
the bathroom because people were trying
to hide and made everyone leave and go
out the front of the hotel and then at
this point Tana was addressing the
people in the back of the hotel so I
just like completely miss any of Tana
and when we got to the front the the the
only part that I personally had with the
security was that they were telling
people to get off the property and I
kind of turned around and said you know
these are kids they don't have a place
to go they can't drive and they were
like we don't care we want them off
Hammond's like okay so yeah I was like
I'm about to adopt a lot of children but
and I you know I keep saying that we
talked about it but we did talk about
like your thoughts on the whole thing in
terms of like Tana and like where you
sit with the whole thing and and what
you feel is right at this point and you
know I kind of think that's that's
interesting to hear
yeah ultimately I
yeah I said this before but I I'm not
trying to bash on Tana and I know you
guys aren't either and the whole time I
was really trying to give her the
benefit of the doubt but at this point
like after the fact and this far past
when the wrongdoing happens there's
really not been an apology and that's
kind of been upsetting and we talked
about sort of you know where to place
the blame and I think it's it's either
equal or like they both I don't know how
to say it but like good times aunt Anna
are both like held responsible for this
it was their event they put it on they
you know promised all of this stuff and
it's not even that they didn't come
through a little you know it's not like
I got the whole thing was taken away
yeah it was like a full full just I mean
I want to call it a scam because that's
what it felt like it felt like I it felt
like I was that fire festival which I
know a lot of people have made that
comparison as well but yeah the only
thing was you weren't stranded on an
island but yeah it's I feel like that's
not the most unfair comparison I just
feel like the thing observing it from
the outside and like we we asked earlier
and there was no you told us there was
no report or information give it out
from good times even to right now like
Sunday afternoon right yeah that's
bizarre man
um they had a tweet that went out that
was a I think it was a statement from
the CEO and it was kind of just saying
like we it's the thing they keep saying
is we never expected this many people to
show up and so that I kind of say like I
don't care like that's not an excuse for
what happened and also like you should
have expected this many people to show
up with the way you were advertising it
um yeah a lot of things that could have
been done ticket cuts or different lines
or you know like it
it was just disorganized and and the
communication has been disappointing to
say the least yeah and um Jenna asked a
good question last time
would you consider if she ever did
another event going to it and if if you
would what would the conditions be yeah
I think it I it's still like if that's
still just like a hard question to think
about because at this point I'm just
like so frustrated I guess um and I I
really was just hoping for her to
finally come out and say like I'm so
sorry that people who cared about me and
these creators like went through this
but there hasn't been an apology and I I
think if there never is one like right
now I'm sort of wondering are they go
ever going to address it again they have
to I feel like but you know if it's if
it's just sort of trying to be a oh it
happened and let's move on I don't think
I would ever go to an event that but her
name was on I guess not like if she was
added a bit but like yeah yeah yeah
but if if she came out and she was like
you know we really messed up here's how
we're gonna fix it and was like true to
that then obviously I would reconsider
I don't think she's a bad person I don't
think she had bad intentions but I just
don't think they were realistic and you
know the funniest part is that this
whole thing was her saying they were
calling me a safety hazard and this
whole thing gets shut down because it's
a safety hazard yeah well I mean it's
it's crazy to think about what actually
went down like all these people young
girls out in the parking lot you know
just getting totally sunburned but also
no water yeah I mean with nowhere to buy
food or water and you said that there
was a small place like up near the
registration line where it looked like
you could buy water but no one would
have known that standing in a parking
lot for five hours
no one's piling on sunscreen because
they didn't know that they were gonna
wait outside for five and a half hours
and yeah you said before when people are
like well you didn't have to stand in
that line but you had already paid $65
you drove from Los Angeles and they kept
telling you the entire time that you
know it's it's gonna keep moving and
it's gonna keep going faster so you can
get in right and Sutton I had the easy
drive it's also like some people flew
from I knew someone who flew from Canada
you know so some people are making
literally international trips for this
and we're being told minute by minute
you know something's gonna change even
like a security guard came by at one
point and was like the lines about start
moving a lot faster and we were like
okay and I mean some people say it did I
don't really notice but yeah I think the
other thing that I thought was really
important was that no one's bags were
getting checked yes yes a backpack or
anything with you or a purse yeah I had
a backpack with me um I assumed that my
stuff didn't get checked because I just
sort of like got in at the end of it um
so I don't know if at any point things
were being checked
but with that amount of people and with
the fact that I still was able to get in
there you know that that right there
means the security is not where it needs
to be for something like this
so she had like security people walking
around but there was no one there metal
detector no security check for your bag
there were no metal detectors I think
there might have been a metal detector I
say I remember seeing like one but I
didn't go through it because the way
basically where I was in line was like
right before if there was a metal
detector I would have been like right
about to go through it but where I was
in line when it came and got shut down I
went around the like little wine keeper
rope thing and went over towards the
door so I didn't go in that direction I
think I saw a video of a metal detector
and like I said earlier I saw a video
like when they opens the doors they were
patting down people like every single
person and I was like well that's gonna
take a while so I don't know if favorite
if that's what it sounds like they were
just bottlenecking thousands of people
through one security check yeah yeah Wow
but then even but then you were in the
event and you had not gotten screened at
all which I imagine was probably the the
same situation for the majority of
people not just some right but like when
Tana came outside and you know it was
like the last ditch like we should at
least make sure that everyone gets a
chance to see me so me and Bella are
gonna go outside you were inside the
events unit you never actually really
saw tan except for when she walked in at
first right from very far away across
the parking lot yeah even when
everyone's standing outside and Hannah's
outside you're talking about potentially
thousands of people that have not been
checked have could have anything in
their bags with them absolutely yeah and
and they went out and I'm pretty sure
their talk of of riots happening with
after they went out and it's like of
course you started a riot which I don't
I wouldn't even call it a riot I think
they started a bit of commotion because
they were excited to see Tana yeah but
yeah it was very unsafe and then because
she went outside we were like oh well
she's definitely gonna come back in here
so we'll just like sit here and wait for
her to come
and address us and she never never
happened yeah so there was no point
where you felt like she liked when you
were waiting for her to come back
there was no payoff like of any sort
there wasn't like an official in person
statement for my management or from
anyone who was just like assuring you
guys that everything was gonna like get
figured out it was just like nothing no
and I think um I think when Gaby came
out was when I was sort of like yeah
this is this is sort of over because she
she was very positive and she was like
we're just gonna keep going and I was
supposed to sing this later but I guess
I'll sing it now and so she likes saying
some of her songs and you can tell yeah
yeah and she raps like Hefner I think
which is standard song and like I saw a
video that yeah she was like really
trying to like keep the positive vibes
and then she left and I think like right
after that somebody came out and was
like you guys are great but this is
canceled for today and we all right I
mean hearing about the security for me
is like this was a [ __ ] show you know it
didn't go right but it could have been
so much worse no much worse like
thinking about the lack of security just
freaks me out a little bit yeah and then
in the aftermath you have not been
refunded right I called my bank which I
encourage everyone else to do just
because I know that there's like time
limits on some of these things but yeah
I I've reached out to every possible
email they've given me just to see what
their response is and then via the email
that they gave us for on the good times
like CEO announcement hasn't responded
and other responses have been sort of
like automatic responses saying contact
the creator or the people who put on the
event so you get a refunds and so it's a
little bit like okay who do I talk to
and and it's tannaz birthday today so
she's she
any of this yet I'm curious to see what
you know how that goes what she when she
addresses it yes like you said there was
a lot of thanking people yeah thanks
everyone for showing up and supporting
me it's the amount of support has been
overwhelming but when you're looking for
my ear saying is you just want a genuine
apology Wow I mean I think that's what
everyone deserves and
I yeah when she so I was watching a lot
of live streams yesterday and when she
had her her Twitter statement finally
she had just come out to address the
people who some of them had been waiting
there since 2:00 a.m. so mind you
there's people who showed up yesterday
not knowing it was canceled and not know
I mean aside from being on Twitter how
are you supposed to figure that out
right like there's no we weren't getting
any correspondence another thing is most
of the VIPs are all of the VIPs paid for
it said that you would get texts
throughout the convention and we got I
think one and then the other two we got
were like after the fact and we're all
messy and like one of them was like
panel happening now and it was that like
10 o'clock at night I saw that and it
said the bad [ __ ] panel is happening on
stage now which happens that morning so
something was messed up with that but
these these girls were were filming when
she came out and you know she came out
to say thank you and make her little
public statement and then she
immediately went out to her birthday
party and then tweeted out her little
manifesto and that's sort of been it
right now and so many people have been
like talking about how Shane has done so
much more than he should like as far as
speaking out for this and I agree but he
it feels like she's the only person
who's truly well it's clear that he
cares yeah it's like he clearly wanted
to be a part of tannaz convention
because he either you know likes Tana
and or wanted to do something nice to
you know collaborate and all this kind
of fell apart and he is not only taking
responsibility for like you know playing
a part in this that in this thing that
really kind of screwed a lot of people
over but he you can tell he's just like
guys I don't know what to do like what
you know what can I do and I'm sure
he'll thing or something out because he
always does but yeah that what is what a
spot to be in
yeah he is an angel
can confirm yeah but so there's also a
lot of creators that were told we're
gonna be there but then they scheduled
them for panels and meet-and-greets that
directly conflicted with their VidCon
times and then we're seeing people tweet
out like I can't go to that I'm gonna be
at VidCon yeah yeah there was I remember
seeing well and I remember seeing I
think it was jennxpenn or someone like
tweeted I'm supposed to have a panel or
maybe was rickey dillion said like I'm
supposed to have a panel at 3:00 is that
still happening yeah I saw that tweet I
mean that that's like the epitome of how
this went
it's like yeah people people that know
what was going on and then Ricky's like
what's going on yes like a top creator
like someone who's like done this [ __ ]
for years it's like do I show up or not
also I don't think it would have been as
funny if it was anyone but Ricky tweeted
yeah he's like what's going on well I
guess well thank you so much again for
talking to us and giving us the time of
day and I don't know I genuinely hope
that they deal with it I hope that good
times is able to you know initiate
refunds for people and yeah you know
yeah pick up the pieces I guess yeah
something I also just wanted to say I
meant to say it at the beginning um I
also realized that they're like way
bigger problems in the world's going on
but this is just sort of an entertaining
catastrophe that happened this weekend
but I've been getting a little bit of
them
you know people are dying Madison and
like yes I know and yes not this is not
the worst thing yeah exactly but it also
like they may not have been there and
like you know I'm not to say that it was
horrible or whatever but yeah it was an
unpleasant day and yeah like you said
you felt like you got a little bit
scammed and it's like just talking about
something because it happened it doesn't
mean that there are other things not
happening
yeah yeah I mean your podcast thing
about it so you know it made news but
yeah thanks again I hope I hope you you
get you get the apology and we were able
to amongst the rest of the people who
were paying for VIP get refunded yeah
well thank you guys yeah and I hope your
sunburn gets better
all right well take care thanks so much
thank you well thank you again to
Madison for joining us that was super
nice of her to take the time and man
while you guys were listening to that
interview I had a nice bite of pizza
that was also part of the pizza earlier
those post mated to me
so guys you should also do the two what
I just did you should maybe not
interview someone but like have some
pizza and make post mates bring it to
you because they're great like that guys
post mates is the app that adds a
delivery option to your favorite
restaurants so if you have a restaurant
nearby your house and you're like damn I
love that restaurant but I am in my PJs
today and I'm not [ __ ] changing post
mates got yet okay I mean like Taco Bell
they don't liver but they do now eat yes
they do Beach yeah we order we I mean
it's like when it first came out post
mates was [ __ ] game-changing cuz
you're like alright I love these
restaurants that I'd never go to because
I don't go out of my house post mates
doesn't judge they just bring you food
you just download the app in order guys
24 hours a day 3 of 6 to 5 days a year
you forget your eggs and milk almond
milk and vegan eggs at the grocery store
you can just postmates a couple items
from the local market like it doesn't
have to be a takeout order it can be any
number of things and right now guys
we're giving you $100 of free delivery
credit when you go to or when you use
the coach energy lien when you sign up
for post minutes right now for your
first seven days of post mates
deliveries guys you will not regret it
is when I see people using other food
delivery services that cringe because I
know postmates so so much better check
it out and tweet us pictures of your
food maybe if you are just hungry yeah
well I was hungry but then
it came in tonight also guys when you're
done eating your food from post mates
get in that bathroom and brush those
teeth with quip electronic toothbrush
get in that bathroom it packs just the
right amount of vibrations into a
slimmer design at a fraction of the
bulkier traditional electric toothbrush
prices okay they're thinking about
efficiency and price and making brushing
your teeth smart easy and affordable for
you okay it's not even it's dude it's so
it's so sleek looking this quick thing
it's like it looks like it's from outer
space
it even has guided our guiding pulses
that alert you when to switch sides so
if you're up early and you're not really
quite firing on all cylinders yet your
toothbrush can help you be a better
person and brush both sides of your
teeth better because hey we're good at
other things but we're not robots we
don't have timers built in us Wow
Jillian the end no it's not the end go
to get quit that's GE TQ u IP comm /
Jenna Julianne and you can get your
first refill pack free with a quip
electric toothbrush and they just start
at $25 check it out thank you sponsors
Thank You Julian so I know that a lot of
you guys like on Twitter when I said we
were going to talk about in the podcast
I got a lot of responses that were like
oh my god he like dragged her and stuff
like that and look we I'm not here to
bash Tana in any kind of way like it's
not cool in my opinion as YouTube
creators ever like bash someone whose
intentions clearly were just like I want
to do something fun for my fans like
that's where this is coming from do I
think that she should be held
responsible for her fair part yes and I
do think what Madison said because
Madison's what 23 years old like you
know this is some of tannaz core fanbase
like when when Madison said you know it
would just it would mean a lot I think
if we just got a genuine apology and I
think that that goes a long way with
people I do too I do too
I'm not gonna drag her and I'm not gonna
bash her but I think that we should talk
realistically about what happened and
how
to prevent this kind of thing in the
future because it shouldn't happen in my
opinion I agree I agree and I think the
culture of tea while it's funny and
enjoyable I know most guys are joking
anyway yeah although I do know that some
of you guys are genuinely mad that I
read in responses we're mad at their
experience and are angry and I think
that you're entitled to that of course
and keep in mind what's that noise it's
Marvel gruffly keep in mind calling it
the light like it doesn't know what it
is he just realized it's in here keep in
mind this is our perspective this is two
people who did not go to Tanic on this
is two people who have never put on a
similar event who have known that that
is such a huge task right like and again
I appreciate where she was coming from
with this I appreciate that she was
taking this negative experience with
VidCon and turning it into something
positive by meeting her fans but doing
it her way I love that and I get why
people were like super hyped about the
idea right
in reality having been to countless of
these events together over the years it
putting one of these things together
just kind of makes my head hurt just
that sentence there are so many
different factors that I'm sure that
they did their best to cover but there's
too many too for any number of people to
successfully put on these events that's
why there's only like two or three right
that's why there's been they've been
doing it's a they've perfected something
well not perfected but they've gotten so
good at something to where most people
like it just that learning curve it's
like you can't just do it well people do
have done smaller personal ones where
it's like I'm meeting 60 people in a
banquet hall like well meet meetups
basic right but my thing is like the
convention style with like the stage and
the walking around in the that's where I
that's where I have my first issue with
this is like at some point I would guess
that Tana you know her sticking it to
the man by doing it right across the
street from VidCon the same weekend as
VidCon because that's that's calculated
right like yeah so her doing that in
setting up this event
was the first mistake and she was so way
in it over her head with that like she
could have done Tana Khan in a smaller
more bite-sized fashion and had the same
message to it but not too big to control
like it was right and I think that you
know I would estimate that that falls on
her management it's not her job to know
a 19 20 year-old girl to know the ins
and outs of what goes into a convention
or what decisions to make out the way
that I want to start talking about it is
this I Tana has this idea what if I have
an alternate VidCon and I can meet
people yep
so she tell I think she works with
Jordan right her manager or whatever and
she probably said to Jordan this is
speculation just making oh yeah again we
weren't there but it was probably
something along the lines of like oh my
god what if we actually did something so
she probably put Jordan or someone in
her team on finding a company that puts
on events and they found good times and
at Ana had said my first red flag when I
saw the tweets about Tanic on being a
real thing was when Tana had promised
that create all of your favorite
creators were just going to be walking
around and I all of a sudden I like I
gives me anxiety because that is a pipe
dream that is the the what everyone
wishes right both us as creators and
people that are coming that want to meet
you like we would love to just like have
a room where everyone could just hang
out that is never gonna happen to us
never gonna happen it's it I can imagine
Shane Dawson who rarely does anything
like VidCon he did some meet and greets
on his book tour but like he had that's
a huge draw once Shane says he's going
this is people a lot of people's one and
only opportunity to maybe meet Shane and
Tana has a promise that him and Rylan
and and their whole group of friends is
just gonna be walking around
sign me the [ __ ] up it cost $65 I'm down
you know what I mean like that to me was
the emptiest biggest misstep which
caused a lot of the like it's such it's
going to be so cool they're just gonna
be walking around yeah it was like
a real-life version of clickbait right
it's where as VidCon is very organized
it's very corporate and is like you you
get into a lottery to get meet-and-greet
and you might never get to meet the
person that you want to meet yeah that's
just how it is yeah and the original
thing that drove Tanna away from VidCon
was her not being a featured creator
which is there for a reason and like I'm
not gonna agree or disagree with their
decision to not make her a feature
creator that year I don't know what the
hell wait I don't but I don't know what
my point is they they'd like I went so
many years to VidCon before I was a
featured creator only I only went is one
year as a future creator it's like yeah
it sucks if you're a creator and you're
not featured and you don't have like the
access to go where all the other
critters go yeah that that sucks but
that system is literally just one of
many examples of why that event succeeds
and Tana Khan didn't it's because
there's order and there separation and
there are rules so it's it's almost like
promising an event with no rules yeah it
sounds great and it's hip on paper but
like when it happens it's gonna hit the
fan well I mean that that was my first
red flag of like this is really
problematic and I think something
problematic can happen because you can't
you just love to believe that Shane
Dawson's hanging out and eating a cotton
candy and you could just go walk up to
him but you and 15,000 other people all
at the same moment like it's not safe
for him and it's not safe for other
people the other thing that I think
happened was like imagine imagine this
imagine me saying to Rome Rome
I want to have my own event not at
VidCon outside of VidCon yeah and I just
want it to be for free and I want
anybody to just be able to walk around
and walk in and just like hang out with
me and then you know you or any of our
friends that want to come she would say
go [ __ ] yourself absolutely go [ __ ]
[ __ ] yourself yes do you know what my
[ __ ] day would look like if we made
that [ __ ] off Jennifer's dry again
no [ __ ] way Rome would ever be like
hell yeah dude like [ __ ] know the people
that work around Tana I imagine were
ripping their hair out of just like this
is so stressful like this is so
terrifying like I I don't know what's
going on like Rome would kill me if I
asked her to do that and this this
falling on her management um in addition
to good times is where most of the blame
right I think that though what she
tweeted out about people just walking
around was irresponsible and I think
that that's partly Tana's fault but
she's also a 19 year old you're I'm not
gonna coddle her like she's an adult
but and she's also I think been to
enough events where she knows that this
is a pipe dream you cannot promise that
people are just gonna be walking around
and that it's free and just just quote
show up and then when 15,000 people who
we're across the street at VidCon are
promised like if I just show up I'm
gonna just be standing next to Shane
Dawson like you better believe they're
gonna come over there because you
promised them something that's just not
correct and and never gonna happen but I
do I just think like the idea of it that
responsibility falls on someone around
her who she chose to help plan this like
good times or her management or whoever
she worked with in conjunction to make
this event happen someone should have
been like I know you want to do that but
it's just not gonna happen
so your tickets can be free but we need
to know how many people are coming you
know what I mean we can't tell people to
just show up that's you're responsible
we can't just like have this big long
line of people waiting outside or that
we need to have a system of knowing when
people are gonna come telling them what
time to come and how many people we plan
on having and can our venue fit that
many people because I I feel like
there's a lot of what Madison said or
like what other people are saying that
they feel like they got scammed is that
they sold too many tickets and they
didn't see anyone that really got in for
free and a lot of the people that just
showed up where that's what they were
told so to then be like we had no idea
that how many people are gonna show up
it's like well then you need to have a
system where people you know who's
coming and who's not coming you have a
way to be in contact with them if
you're gonna the next day wake up and
change venues it's just not safe I don't
know there's a lot of people that are
actually very angry as they have the
right to be the thing that makes me I
think frustrated and angry is I'm very
glad that nothing happened both for Tana
and the people that were there but that
that was a really big opportunity for
something absolutely terrible to happen
yeah and that in and of itself is really
not okay and it's not the type of thing
that anyone should be in that position
like Tana shouldn't be in that position
those people those those young girls
should not have ever been in that
position and I that upsets me and it's
it's a it's aunt Anna and it's on her
her management and her people and on
good times because you know there there
was just a lot of missed opportunities
for them to just organize it a little
better by someone just posing the
question of like hey what what's what's
the protocol for if we tell people to
just show up and we can't get everybody
in the building
so many conversations didn't happen that
we're supposed to happen listen when a
kid gets in behind the driver's seat of
a car and crashes it you can't get out
of the kid you get mad at the adult who
got in the passenger seat and said go
for it okay good job I also don't like
that she took the opportunity when so
many people showed up she took that as
an opportunity to thank her fans for
support I felt like that was
inappropriate it was the wrong time to
say oh my god I'm so overwhelmed by the
love and support from you guys that may
be true and we know you are but right
now yeah like there this is a problem
it's like you know she's not calling it
as it is upon talking to Madison and
hearing her account which I can only
estimate is it's very similar to
thousands and thousands of other girls
experience at Tana Khan is troubling
when I heard about the security it
freaks me out in this day and age in
this [ __ ] climate when [ __ ] goes down
at conventions now that every convention
is now stepping up the security every
convention is spending thousands and
thousands of dollars in security
measures to make sure everything is as
secure as possible and Tana throws an
event where they are literally bottle
necking twenty fifteen thousand people
twenty thousand people into one security
checkpoint which definitely means that
90% of the people are not being screened
right that bothers me
that's the part where I have the biggest
bone to pick because if I had a kid who
went to Tana Khan
I would literally never forgive myself
if something happened because I didn't
do my research and I'm sure so many
parents are having their kids come home
right now maybe on a flight maybe in a
car and they're like wow this is crazy
that it happened and I feel like a lot
of parents are probably having a wake-up
call hey maybe next time I should do a
little [ __ ] research here and make
sure that this event that my kid is fine
hell-bent on buying tickets and going
driving - flying - whatever it has some
sort of semblance of structure and
safety because that is just there's
inexcusable to have bad security like
that especially with that volume of
people like I get like I get you want to
be Logan Paul and you want to run to a
crowd of people that's your funeral
okay yes you're putting a lot of people
in danger and [ __ ] you for doing that
but you're not organizing an event and
and not enforcing serious security and I
don't really care what good times
excuses for that there really is no
excuse right because we talked we talked
to someone who was there and we got the
truth of someone who went to the event
and literally got in without that wasn't
sad a backpack could I have whatever in
it and had any other people do exactly
what she did that's it there's no
there's literally no excuse for that
that's I mean that's where yeah and I
mean I am a little bothered in that I
feel like one lesson I learned very
young pretty fast was like a rule number
one of life is like don't [ __ ] with
people's money
don't [ __ ] with people's money if you're
gonna charge someone money for something
there needs to be a fair exchange of
goods or services or something or else
you cannot charge them and the the
situation that Madison described about
not being getting she's not getting
refunded and there's not really a clear
way for that to happen yep that should
be set in place always for an event for
any sale okay
what happens if someone's like not
satisfied with what they paid for what's
the protocol for them to get refunded
and the fact that there is none right
now is very it's upsetting because I
imagine there's a lot of people where
that $65 was a lot to come by and that
they saved up for let alone you know
travel costs and things like that so
there there needs to be a protocol for
those people getting refunded if not
everyone because I don't think anyone
really got what they paid for what they
were told and I think the the
comparisons to fire festival are
interesting because that guy is is he
currently going to trial for wire fraud
and [ __ ] like that yeah
but I mean this is what this is a very
serious thing when you charge people for
money and but for you know you're
promising them something for $65 and you
don't give them that and I think that
that needs to be rectified immediately
as soon as possible because it's it's
just not okay I agree and I agree I
think that a general rule in life don't
[ __ ] with people's money won't [ __ ] with
people's money like you can't pay people
late you can't [ __ ] ask for money
borrow it not pay it don't [ __ ] with
people's money man don't do it you're
asking for a world of hurt but I think
that it's it's frustrating that you know
for someone that was like I really want
to make this free event it is sad and
frustrating to hear that most of them
paid $65 most of them yeah I mean we
don't know that to be true but also take
medicines advice if you had gone to ten
accountants spent money call your bank
yeah that seam report it and just get
your money back like thank you bye I
think as a general rule of thumb Julian
and I because I have been to a bunch of
events that were not very fun you know
what I'm saying and they're all over the
world like sometimes you have no control
and at this point like we know people at
VidCon and people at playlist or if
you're going you you have a better
understanding what to expect but we can
invite you to a lot of things that we've
never been to before and we don't we
don't know what's gonna happen and it
creates a really stressful environment
for Rome at times because you know while
I'm
out there just physically meeting people
and saying hello she's around the corner
being like what the [ __ ] is going on you
know
our general rule of thumb is we don't go
to events where it's the first of its
kind ever like just in general neither
one of us were invited to Tanic on I'm
sure if we had expressed Satana that we
really wanted to go I can't imagine that
she would be like [ __ ] you guys like
she's a nice girl we have nothing
against her but it's just not something
I would ever do but just from experience
we wouldn't go to an event of the first
year that emphasis on the from
experience here that does help and I
think as in the future so dude I just
want to talk about how to make this
better in the future no I think that's I
think that's the only part that's the
only positive discussion to have right
now Yeah right like pate you know refund
people make it right and moving forward
how can we how can we have this
discussion about making making this a
possibility to be something as positive
as an attendee of something I can't
imagine for the people that are super
hardcore Tanna fans for me to be like if
it's the first of its a first event of
that kind like maybe set that year out
and try to go next year for a lot of
those people are like no I'd go to
anything she put on that's fine but I'm
talking about in general with
conventions or things like that if it's
the first one and you can help it to not
go to the first one just to like suss
out how it went and you know maybe go to
the next year if it played out okay
that's a general rule that we try to
follow that usually pans out pretty well
for us right yes it's a good rule to
have if it's an established convention
you have a far more high chance of
getting what you paid for or having the
experience that you had hoped for or
just something that seems a little more
fair or plan to organize which is always
the best
like I just if I'm gonna travel there
and go to it anyways that like to also
not be stressed out of my mind please
then thank you yeah I I wanna I just
want to give a shout out to Shane
because I feel like he handled this
whole thing really well and it's like I
would dread being in his position I'd
absolutely dread agreeing to Tanic on
having you blow up in your face
and then feeling like it's somehow your
fault you know and getting mean tweets
because I know people are mean and it
sucks I don't think people are mean I
think he's getting a lot of tweets that
are like I drove all the way from
Oklahoma to meet you and and I'm really
sad because I didn't get to know of
course there's those tweets but that I'm
saying there's also media mates cuz I've
seen some that are like a tag name and
whatever but I just think he's handling
well and you know what if I had faith in
anyone on the internet to make this
right for their fans the way he would do
it it's Shane it's like he has he is the
way to do this and I'm confident he's
gonna make it right with people I don't
know I just I just really I empathize
and I would hate hate hate to have been
in that spot because it's not fair to
you it's not fair at the end of the day
it's like not Shane's fault at all but
it's also like he's now and he's now in
this he's gonna deal with it yeah well I
mean if Tana does one in the future I
think she hopefully has learned the
lesson like I hope to never see
something that says you're all of your
favorite creators we'll just be walking
around I hope that I never see that
again in any context because it's not
safe it's not safe and it's also not
safe to promote that as a reality ever
and I hope that if she does want to do a
truly free event that they just make it
so people can register a lottery online
for free it cost zero dollars there's
nothing wrong with that at all
for having people pay zero dollars but
you do need to know who and how many
people are coming to your event like you
need to be in context or like contact
with them before and after your event
because the the lack of communication I
think was really frustrating for people
and if you are gonna charge money there
needs to be a way that you make sure
those people are getting what they paid
for because it's just I'm in it really
sucks it really sucks
it's yeah shitty put again I think in
the next couple of days it's gonna be
interesting to see how things are
handled yeah I mean I I commend her for
trying and I think her heart was in the
right place and in a good place but like
Madison said I think an apology would go
a long way
and I am a little upset at the the
security risk that she created but it
wasn't her personally it was a
combination of her her team and good
times and good times really like tannaz
a 19 20 year old girl it's like I want
to make this event good good times you
apparently do this for a living and it's
just unacceptable there's no excuse for
good times so I mean maybe she looks
into working with someone else but also
you know having a controlled amount of
people at an event it's usually a little
better than telling people to just show
up and then acting surprised when 15,000
people show up yep um I think the the
concept of having a smaller alternative
VidCon is also interesting it's
interesting because I you know I've
thought about that it's it's an
interesting thought especially the way
like if if you're able to take away
parts of VidCon that you don't like and
make that your event that's wonderful
just do it the right way and do your
homework and make sure you're you know
you're having good people set it up and
make sure that there's food and water
just make sure people just here's here's
a good rule do you want to go to that
event if the answer is yes you did it
right if the answer's no you did it
wrong right no one wants to go wait in
the parking lot for five hours and get
sunburned without water yeah well I
think a lot of that falls on good times
I do too and I would be interesting I
agree with you in the this is not a
badging Tanna party I have no interest
in bashing Tana I think she's nice and I
think her intentions were in the right
place so I just wanted to make that
clear like I'm not I'd be interested to
know how many tickets they sold versus
how many people that venue holds I doubt
we'll ever release it because it's
irresponsible but I mean that's this
that kind of thing is like they hired
good times to do the services that they
said that they were going to do and to
handle it and they didn't because if you
wanted to plan a convention you contact
an event
company and they gave you that I would
be livid at then I would even I would
even think that there's grounds for a
lawsuit there you never know I mean if
you're an event company there's got to
be certain guarantees or promises that
come with hiring you to make an event
and if none of those were yeah I think
it was a perfect storm of good times
clearly not executing what they said
they're gonna execute along with Tanna
irresponsibly saying it's free come by
and if everyone everyone is just gonna
be walking around
it was a combination of a lot of things
that made it yeah and unfortunately some
people traveled a really long way which
we feel for you but I mean at the same
time like I understand that like if you
told me 4-0 or $65 I could be or sitting
out with Shane Dawson yeah it will
happen my car [ __ ] yeah yeah you know
yeah I and I guess I I guess I my point
where would you want to go to that event
that might be nullified with with that
right there because it's like if you
promise something that isn't delivered
then you can't really blame the people
who came because they were promised
something mm-hmm you know on paper the
event looks great sort of well it's like
selling someone a book for $65 and half
the pages are just blank like if you're
charging money for something you need to
give them what they paid for him and the
the gift bags she had said had like a
sticker a condom rubber wrist wrist pan
just like not a $65 goodie back yeah
well I will say that I was surprised
when I saw Madison story and other
people's videos from the event that they
had foot like clearly focused so much on
making it like a convention when I think
they could have just made it a large
meet-and-greet you know like focused
more on because that's really like in my
experience at the the conventions like I
mean the huge ones were there like yeah
I just like to walk around like that
part's very fun but like people's
favorite parts of going to the
conventions is when they actually get a
chance to meet someone who they've
traveled to see and if they maybe focus
their energy a little less on the
lighting in the main stage and the [ __ ]
going on if you if you just
had like breakaway rooms where people
can safely meet yeah you know yeah also
I think a mic stand would have been in
order cuz that kid was having to hold
the mic for his friend I'm just
I think I'm overall I was hopeful that
it would go really well and I was
hopeful that it would be a cool thing
and I think everybody hoped that you
know it's sad and it's sort of
disappointing that it turned into a
little bit of a nightmare
and I just I do think that an apology
would go a long way for people like
Madison who felt like you know they paid
money for something that they didn't get
and I hope it also doesn't discourage
her in the future from trying again like
I do wish Tana luck like I feel like you
know you sort of had an opportunity and
people are feeling a little not so cool
on it right now but like if she wanted
to try it again and really stepped up
the what the event was and put safety
first because this whole like we're
getting shut down and safety is my
number-one concern
like if safety was your number-one
concern knowing who and how many people
were coming to your event would be
number two yeah so uh it is just a
little frustrating to hear something
like that feeling like all the fire
marshals shutting it sounds like I just
feel bad for so many different people
likes it I feel bad with the people who
attended I feel bad for the hotel
employees next door I feel bad for the
security workers who were probably
yelled at the whole day honestly yeah
you know it's like the whole thing's but
I I hope it doesn't discourage Tana if
she wanted to try again
I agree start small start small have a
small thing they can be free tickets but
you need to know who's coming to your
event and how many people and I hope it
doesn't discourage other creators from
trying to do something new because it
wasn't that long ago that Hank and John
Green literally made VidCon and didn't
know what it was when they started
making it and didn't know how to run an
event and as a person that went to those
like yeah you could [ __ ] tell like
it's not really super great in here you
know but like that's not much better
than what Ana did
Tanna just did it next to VidCon and
like told people about it so it got a
little crazy but the
first couple years the conventions are
always rough because there's just a lot
of stuff that comes up so I don't think
it's I think it was on a bigger scale
because of the circumstances yeah but
you know most first year events anybody
will tell you it's just like yeah it
kind of sucked mm-hmm so I mean you as
an attendee maybe just skip that first
year hope for the best but I don't think
tannaz event went necessarily so much
worse than other first-year events it
was shut down yeah well you think about
first year events right and like what we
talked about how we don't go to them
that's true right that curve brings the
Tanner grade from a D to like maybe a C
or something right cuz it's like it is a
first-year event so I get I get risen
yeah but I'm I'm the the videos of her
going outside in the crowd and you know
stuff like that
they make me worried and it makes me
frustrated because how many times do we
see people do this and you know the
potential potential consequences of
doing something like that if there's a
large crowd of people don't go out there
and say I'm so sorry I can't like I
can't hang out with you like it's not
safe
you're and to see people doing things
that are unsafe it's just a little
frustrating because you and many people
around you believe like it's gonna be
fine like they're just regular people
but that's it's not it's not just look
at this when these things happen like
yeah I'm glad that nothing happened
but people need to be refunded and Tana
does in the future please please put
safety first and uh at least she tried
true but I do feel for you guys that
went and that are angry you can leave
your experiences or your anger in the
comments if you want to or if you're
like Madison I think Madison is you know
a little frustrated but she's certainly
not like she went to Disneyland after
she got a she's fine she's not like
yelling and screaming and angry you know
but thank you guys for
listening to his talk about this
hopefully we had something to offer that
he felt was worthwhile but yeah we want
to hear what you don't have to say so
hit us up in the comments for sure yeah
have a good week
be safe and now instead I'll see you
next week
[Music]